seeing yes he just to the restroom we're
gonna wait
just thank you and welcome everybody to
the work session on House Bill 608 I
will call it to this meeting to order um
House Bill 608 was introduced by
representative Jess Edwards um looking
at the potential challenges um and
potential shocks to the system of in the
um developmental disabilities Community
as it moved to a conflict free case
management and several other changes
that needed to be done in order to come
into compliance with uh CMS requirements
um it it was a process where we had this
bill in order to include a pilot program
um and there have been some requests to
go through a waiver process um however
we moved ahead with a July 1st
implementation date and we have some
people here in the audience who have had
firsthand experiences with what has
happened since July 1st and the process
before and um given that we missed the
window with this bill specifically for
this Pro problem but there are multiple
other changes to the system coming um I
think it would be good to see sort of
what happened get a bit of an after
action and see if the pilot project idea
may be something that helps us going
forward to um avoid some more
disruptions um so uh with that um let's
say actually Jess would you like to
representative Edwards would you like to
get up and speak first thank
you I don't know that we're all at form
but I'm representative Jess Edwards I
think I know you all um it's been about
9 months since I introduced 608 the
concept of 608 is represent on just said
was to um encourage or actually mandate
that the uh Department execute a pilot
project because we knew there was a
radical change to the building system
and that was causing a great deal of uh
concern and for whatever reason um
because I wasn't part of the minutia of
of what happened from the
introduction um neither did the bill get
passed nor did the department choose to
implement a pilot project they did not
require a law to do a pilot project
that's just good basic management it's
almost it's not 101 level management but
it's certainly you know 301 or 401 it's
not graduate level stuff if you're going
to do something very complex it affects
a great number of stakeholders and a
very dramatic and systemic way uh you
want to do a pilot project roll it out
in a graceful way the department didn't
do that and it was chaos they created
chaos they created unnecessary burdens
on the care providers to to deal in a
transition period where they were doing
without their regular uh battle rhythm
of reimbursements for the work that they
were doing and that created um great
deal of anxiety and financial stress to
where some unusual measures had to be
implemented to um essentially prepay
some money so that so some of the strong
area agencies could float some of the
less capable area agencies and so so we
ended up with this huge system of
workarounds that are also now causing
secondary and tertiary problems as the
department tries to roll it back so my
bottom line is I just want to leave you
with the idea that it 608 was a good
bill uh real life real history is
demonstrated that the department blew it
and the the department needs to um
consider in the future doing pilot
projects for similar roll outs of major
systems
changes um so so 608 is moot for the
issue in which it was intended but to
the chair's point of view there are two
other opportunities where the bill could
be repurposed to address other major
rollouts uh one of them uh and and um
there's people here in the crowd that
would be better to go into the detail
but to just give you the two highlights
one is um the um electronic verification
system that Services uh ordered and
performed and has been taken care of
properly and that's going to trigger all
of the billing
that's the one I think probably needs to
to be piloted still and then um and I
forget the second one already because I
got obsessed with the with the first one
so um so I hope that I mean you you can
go ahead and recommend killing this bill
you know because uh you know it's
overcome by
events but because of the lethargy in
the department and their failure to do
the right thing with p
projects I don't know that I would
recommend doing away with 608 I think I
would recommend that you consider
repurposing 608 for another high
priority roll out to force the hand of a
department that seemed unwilling to do
basic Common Sense management and I'm
sorry I was so harsh uh but this is why
I think they sent the lawyer instead of
the The
Operators so so that's it if you have
any questions I'd be happy to address
them but there are other people here
representative
Leber I just have a point of order um I
I
wonder I me I would take the position
that if the decision is to pursue
repurposing this to deal with completely
different programs that that would
require a minimum notice that we have
changed the purpose of the bill so that
people affected who might not have
decided to come to this hearing because
they didn't think it was going to affect
them would have notice um my my my
preference would be to itl the bill and
then take up representative Edwards very
Salient points going forward thank you
representative
Merchant thank you um following up on
represent who's sorry see you moment
I concur I think one of the things we
could do if we do decide to repurpose
something versus iing it that would
probably trigger a non- gerain Amendment
yeah that's to to your point right so
therefore if we do create a non-main
amendment that would actually create
another hearing which should continue to
go forward with it without having to
reinduce an LSR is that right okay thank
you that's so if I may comment on those
two things because they're really close
to each other I I think the way I wrote
608 it's uh flexible and non-specific
enough to where picking up one of the
other
BDS projects wouldn't necessarily be
nin's remain but because I listened to
representative Weber on on everything
she says about procedure and policy I I
think she's absolutely right that uh it
would it would take some more effort if
you wanted to repurpose the bill we I've
missed the window for introducing ing
new legislation in January so so so I
sort of look at this 608 as maybe
something that's not dead that that we
could recast and continue to work on but
I I'll I'll defer to the experts on the
on the committee um representative
Edwards um I know that there are the two
upcoming changes the rate work and that
electronic billing issue um but I is
there an expectation that there's other
changes in the future because
um my choice would be that there's going
to
be that we've already seen that this one
was fumbled um throughout the process
perhaps um requiring that good business
project process of having a pilot
program Whenever there might be a
significant change to the system might
be the best Ultimate uh way to proceed
so that it's not just these programs but
um anything that's a major significant
change so so would you like feedback on
that yes please I I I would be reluctant
as a kind of a small government leaning
guy to legislate that the state shall
use good business
practices this is an example of a good
business practice that anyone who's gone
and got an education and management
would know about so so if if you were to
legislate that they do pilot projects
for well-defined kinds of
scenarios then that would just sort of
open the question to what other Common
Sense business practice might we want to
legislate should should we legislate
that they learn that you know you debit
on the left credit on the right they I
mean it's just I I I don't know how to U
Define it in a way in which we're not
setting up a precedent for over
management from A legislature but that's
my thought I thank you um representative
Nagel thank you um I'm I'm a little I
want to understand a lot better what
what went on with what's happening right
now because A&M made five major
recommendations for a new
system um you know billing was just a
small part of it you know you know
looking at tiered waiver systems
reimbursement rates and I they one of
the biggest recommendations they made
was a new it system that was really
expensive um how to deal with weight
lists and so on and so forth I mean what
what part of those five elements was
actually dealt with and and what was
done thank you for the question I in
effect none of them got dealt with one
of them has already kind of come and
gone its window of opportunity and that
was the pilot project of the direct
billing methodology what that meant is
that CMS changed their rules a few years
ago in the state bought some time
kicking the can down the road a little
bit until they their backs got up
against the wall on this one July
deadline uh and what needed to happen
was instead of having uh the department
reimbursing the area agencies and the
area agencies taking care of the
payments to the service providers they
were trying to get the middlemen out CMS
was trying to get the middlemen out and
and creating service providers doing
direct billing so as you know as a a
practitioner a private practitioner if
you if you're if in your Billing System
gets screwed up and you don't get
reimbursements for 3 months longer than
you expected or longer that's that
causes you a real problem you can't pay
your
administrative administrator your
medical records people it's it's it's
the same sort of implication for the
service providers through the um in in
in the DD community so there's still
like you said there are four other
possibilities two of them seem to be
more ripe for pilot project
yes just a quick followup so in other
words we can still use this bill for
those four elements to create a pilot
project to look at the whole program I I
would defer to whatever representative
Weber says uh I I think you can but I'm
reckless so um I I I would I would defer
to her if I may yes there's nothing that
prohibit prohibits that that I know
of what is required though and I would
obviously defer to the house clerk on
this but what is required is when you
exceed the scope of the original Bill
such that people who might be affected
by it and need to have notice of what's
going to happen so they can come and
talk to us about it so what we would
actually be doing is restarting the
hearing process now and finishing it by
November 17th which is not impossible
possible but
it's a stretch and it would require a
great deal of commitment and I certainly
uh I'm sure we're going to hear from the
Department as well and and perhaps
anybody else who is affected on this
part of it
before making that determination that
we're going to put that effort
in um and then to CL sorry oh perfect
represent
Merchant I'm going to rely upon
represent Weber our knowledge parli
attorney
wise if we do introduce an amendment
that's not in
gerain do that mean that we still have
to do something by November 17th we do
absolutely thank you on Deadline yes um
and then I have a question for you
representative Edwards um is the um rate
work and the electronic billing system
both included within the Alvarez and uh
Marshall public sector Services
recommendations
I'm hearing a whisper in the back that
yes and I I actually would have said yes
too
so so then I think that well we would
need to see that if we do look to the
rest of the A&M processes obviously the
deadline of starting it no later than
July 1st would be a problem um but there
but more of it may still stay applicable
since those are within their
representative Merchant again I'm going
to rely upon repesent
Weber my understanding if we want to
introduce an
LSR after the deadline that could be
approved by the rules committee so
therefore we could make it motion to the
rules committee to introduce another LSR
late in this time to help address some
of the issue versus going through a n
gerain amendment is that
correct that that would also be a
possibility um you would have to um
arrange with the speaker
for um for a meeting of the rules
committee and I think there are other
ways to let me look them up while you
talk among yourselves so so the need for
another for legislation to require a
pilot project would be obviously
obviated if the department just said it
was going to do
one the
legislation makes them do it when they
don't want to do it and I would think
after the disaster that they just
Unleashed upon the beneficiaries the DD
system uh that they have learned a
lesson and that they would want to come
and work on a pilot project outside of a
legal
requirement thank you merch
representative
[Music]
Merchant in regards
to the oversight committee for DHHS does
that that committee have a role here
where it could hold the department more
accountable to what's happening versus
trying to do it strictly through
legislation which is going to be
difficult at this point in
time look I've been on the oversight
committee I think a couple of terms I
think representative Weber's been on
there too and I've I've gotten lazy I
just defer to her whenever a question
like that comes up but I I I I I I don't
think the oversight committee has within
its uh statutory Authority the ability
to hold somebody accountable or to hold
a department accountable what what what
we can do is is we can you know make a
motion and vote on it in the in the in
the oversight committee and um and maybe
publicize it I I we've never done that
in the two years I've been there though
so it would be uh an experience that
I've not had
yet and if I may my experience of the
oversight committee is it's not uh a
body that
can uh direct anybody to do anything in
the same way that we would have I mean a
bill has to be done with Bill
formalities uh it's certainly a place
for discussion and um concern and often
resolution as as representative Edwards
says it's perfectly possible right now
for the Department to do a pilot program
uh so they don't need our bless for that
but uh the if if the desire is to compel
a particular action that can't happen
and I I will also say that the the um
oversight committee is pretty chocka
block with a lot of different things it
could have a subcommittee to work on
this but again the process there is
going to be very spread out and I'm
sorry I'm not seeing the piece
of the rules that speaks to late
drafting so I'm I'm not going to address
that at this
point Thank um representative Nel thank
you you're welcome um I I'm still I I
assume we're going to hear the other
side of this today I I don't know if the
Department's prepared to defend
themselves against my beating them up in
public like this uh but they should just
accept that what I said is accurate what
I'm getting at is I I I'm struggling
with why we need to it this thing at all
I mean it seems to me that when I look
at what was supposed to be covered in
this pilot program much of it's still in
existence and still can go forward the
way it is there's only one thing here
that it seems that has been addressed
that's the billing there's four other
things here that haven't been addressed
that's why I didn't like the word non
German because I just don't sorry yeah
thank you thank you um I I I think that
perhaps now I think we've had some good
discussion about what we what path we
may be able to take I'd like to hear
some more about the actual
implementation of this and um how big of
an impact it's had on some of the area
agencies impation of the billing yes the
implementation of the billing
change me yes thank
you
and after you come up if I could have
you introduce yourselves that'd be
[Music]
wonderful good afternoon I'm Matt cero
I'm the CEO for Region 8 one sky
Community Services we're in area
agency Chris whan Chief Financial
Officer at one sky community services
and Brian gdle uh controller for on Sky
Community Services
um so I first off I want to thank you
for allowing us to come um and to hear
about what our direct experience has
been we do not represent um any other
area agencies I can talk to the
specifics of the conversations I've had
with providers but I believe um we have
some documentation that we'd like to
share with you that shows our
financials um and what's happened the
last 3 months um since the
implementation and then also talk about
some of the fixes that um need to occur
in an impact statement we're going to
try to keep it very brief and very high
level um but if you have questions feel
free to chime in um with us
so
sure is it okay if I bring up uh yes
please that help if we can read along
thank you the first uh handout that
we'll be looking at is a high level
summary of our finances um actual
activity at one sky for the first
quarter of FY
sure so this will be the first one that
we look
at okay
so I'd like to just briefly speak about
what led um to our current
situation um over the past fiscal year
so January of 2022 through June of
2023 um we had been implementing some
changes to our system um in which case
you know we supplied all um all
available data and an accurate and
compliant format um and during this
transition
um the the changes somehow got into the
new system incorrectly which has caused
a significant um a significant problem
with our ability to bill um and receive
uh appropriate funding for our service
author
izations um we also had a um a blackout
period during this transition from um
the third week in June through the third
week in
July um which again caused significant
uh cash flow um and financial impli
implications for um not only us but the
system as a whole um two questions you
provided that information to the
department um all of that data the
systems data that you provided yes yes
sorry and the blackout period what was
the impact of a can you explain to us
what a blackout period means so the the
blackout period would be um a stop of
any and all billing of services um
during that period of time um Services
may be rendered but they would not be we
would not be able to bill for those
Services until the blackout period ended
um which dipped into our uh our
financial
reserves okay thank
you uh the first item I'll look at is
the um summarized financial statement
that has the the colored columns this is
a snapshot of our activity for the first
quarter of
24 uh The Columns that you'll see that
says monthly budget The Columns in in
purple they are uh an indication of what
we as an agency uh had projected that we
would earn um and what we would incur as
expenses in a given month if the system
if all if there were no issues that we
had encountered on the other side of
July 1st so on a monthly basis we would
anticipate earning about $199,000 to the
bottom
line however the next column over that
you see that's titled fy2 24 activity
within each given month is an actual
representation of what we actually
received as Revenue against actual
expenses that we incurred for that given
month so you'll see in the month of July
we actually only earned or received uh
just under $11,000 in revenue for that
month which left us with over a half
million dollar loss for the month of
July what you'll see next to it is a
column that's called
FY 2023 activity processed in each
specific month and what that means is
there's there's activity from FY 23
based on the timing that is spilled in
fy2 24 so when you see that column while
we may have uh re receive some Revenue
that's for prior fiscal year activity
and it's paying out expenses for the
prior fiscal year so it's against
obligations we've already incurred and
that that has a direct impact because
that draws down
our uh Financial reserves that we have
to draw on because we're not bringing in
additional revenue and that carries
forward each subsequent month to the
point that at this point in the fiscal
year at the end of September it was our
expectation that we would have incurred
about a
$57,000 positive uh bottom line but
year-to dat actually we're about
$900,000
um behind about $850,000 ,000 in the red
based on this inability to properly or
adequately build for the services that
have been rendered and we've been built
for and have paid
out
one one thing I'd like to add is that
about uh August 15th we met with the um
with BDS and dhj Leadership because
there was no uh billing that was
occurring for us and we met together as
a system and they brought in emergency
funding so that emergency funding equals
$1.6 million and that I would refer to
as a bridge loan getting us to the place
to where we're able to continue to bill
the way BDS and dhss looks at that is
that those funds are actually
prepayments and even though we're not
providing them with the detail that 1.6
million is money that they're paying us
for services rendered which which again
means that we're still short $900,000 to
the state now what is happening now is
that CMS can't allow double billing to
occur so even though we're billing for
services now and we're only being paid
45 cents on the
dollar in order for BDS to come into
compliance with CMS Financial rules they
have to collect that $1.6 million back
from us by December 31st
so the people who aren't paying us we
had to borrow money from them because
they weren't paying us and now we have
to repay them back the money that they
didn't pay us to begin with and it's
essentially going to take any and all of
our cash flow plus some by the end of
the year now I I do want to recognize
that we had a meeting two days ago with
BDS and you know there are some very
great people working there that are
solution focused and they're helping us
to get through that um but this is the
operation and the environment we're
operating
in thank
you sorry representative Weber and then
Nagel thank you and I can appreciate the
depths of the
problem what I am wondering is we have a
bill in front of us and and now that I
have refreshed my memory we we only
spoke at the last hearing about one
phase of the five phases um but the bill
itself isn't limited to that
so I'm going to defer to the house clerk
about whatever we need to do next uh but
what I I'd love to hear from you is if
we were to take this bill as it is is
what which is what I'm hearing saying
said from various people and just now
start impose a mandate of a pilot
project upon the current chaos plus
whatever anybody's doing right or wrong
to resolve the current chaos are we
helping
matters a th% yes I I mean I have a
couple asks of you and I'm going to get
out of okay if if you're getting to that
I'm sorry if I was Prett no no I I
I would like Chris to finish his I'm
sorry um but I do have a couple asks of
you and I will tell you that everything
we're talking about today the evv the
rate committee uh work and
implementation of the rates is all under
that original Marcel and Alvarez uh or
Alvarez and Marcel plan so we're we're
not talking about different topics we're
talking about the same thing this is
Phase One of a five act play and
we have had control as an area agency
system and and again I'm only speaking
for one sky but in general we've had
control of the air agency system for 40
years and for 40 years this has worked
and it's worked well BDS has had control
of it for 90 some odd days and some of
the impact statements that I've gotten
from providers are significant and I
know some of them had sent them in so I
won't you know read them off um
but the system in my humble opinion
can't take much more and we have vendors
that are into their line of credit they
are um only getting paid you know like
we are pennies on the dollar um and that
and I will say to bds's credit they are
cash and fusing but we're still $900,000
short and they want their money back and
we're only getting 45 cents on the
dollar so it it doesn't make a lot of
sense um and again there there are
actual people at BDS that have common
sense and they make sense but I don't
think they're in
charge um you know and I I'm not going
to mention names even though I really
want to because I really like them a lot
and I think they're smart and I actually
think they're solution focused and
minded um and I'd love to mention their
names but I won't
because I don't want to point anyone out
for good or bad I don't want to find
fault in any one person I don't want to
pin this on anyone what what I'm asking
and I think through Jess's uh
representative Edward's bill
is we need to stop we need to fix what
we've done at this point and stop
everything else it's a reasonable
request that doesn't mean that we stop
it
indefinitely by any stretch of the in
ination some of this stuff is actually
good ideas but we need to stop we need
to fix the financial situation of the
system as a whole because I have
providers that are on their line of
credit right now for
$750,000 $500,000
$250,000 that's just three people three
companies off the top of my head um get
them right sized get their budgets fixed
um BDS has cut uh rman board budgets and
just so you understand that's based on
actual cost of living
so the state is required to provide
support and that support is housing food
electricity heat these are essential
functions this is what the state needs
to pay for uh aside from services to
keep people safe in the community and
they've cut people's room and board
budgets their companies by 130,000 in
one case 140,000 is um so that means
that that provider has to absorb that
cost and to continue providing the
services
now in talking to BDS they've said that
they just don't have money in that line
item so my thought process would be
continue to overspend the line item and
come to the legislature and say hey we
haven't touched this line item in 12
years we are now at 4 million 3 million
3 and A5 million 4 and a half million
whatever they're at this is what we need
to adequately adequately support people
versus causing additional cash flow uh
issues for people who aren't even
getting paid for the services they're
providing and the state has a
contractual obligation to pay everyone
and they're out of contract and that's a
specific performance issue from a legal
side um and I think because we are all
on the Human Services side we're we're
not the kind of people that are going to
twist arms and break them to to get our
money um because realistically the money
that we get like if you look at our
whopping profit of $50,000 for 3 months
work um um I mean that's just enough to
be able to keep our line of credit
because you have to have debt income
ratios at I mean just because we're a
nonprofit doesn't mean that we're you
know outside of the realm of what is
required to be financially stable so and
just so you're all aware we had an
individual that was in the hospital for
two years that last year we made a
conscious decision to buy a house to
take that individual out of the hospital
and then we retrofitted that house the
cost of the home is
$530,000 we then had to put $600,000
into it and that is our money that's not
the state's money we didn't get any kind
of um anything for that we did that
because it was the right thing to do
because that
individual was so medically needy that
even nursing homes wouldn't take the
person because they recognized them as
palet of care but rather than keeping
them sequestered in a hospital where
they're taking up three tertiary care
beds for their care
um we decided to make that investment
and I am very lucky that I have a board
that listens to my crazy ideas to do the
right thing um and so had I
known what we were going to be going
through this year I would not have
bought that house no matter how much I
wanted to I wouldn't have done it
because I'm looking at tying off a
tourniquet plan to our business and I've
been told we're the money we're going to
get the money no matter what and that's
great but if you're asking me to repay a
loan of $1.6 million so that you can
look good for CMS but it's going to
crush my company and we sat down last
week and we figured out how many people
we have to lay off we figured out what
business lines that cost us money that
we don't get money on because we're a
nonprofit that we have to cut uh and
services that we have to dial back on
and again we're we're being told we're
going to get the money and by the people
who are telling me that I believe them
but when we get it is going to make all
the difference in the world and if we're
being forced to repay $1.6
million and we're only getting 45 cents
on the dollar and we only have a profit
margin of one and a quar per. yes okay
one and a quarter percent how do we do
that it's the math doesn't make
sense
so so my followup is that still hasn't
answered my question because I don't
see I see the gravity and enormity of
the
problem and it's a morass what I don't
see is how if we simply do something
like
update what we have in front of us with
new start dates new end dates and say
Department you can't do
anything because I think it says that in
here somewhere and I I will say I have
to read it over again a little more
carefully because I was remembering it
as being smaller than what the language
is if we say Department you can't do
anything until you've after you've done
these pilot projects I'm concerned that
that language may actually get in the
way of some of the workarounds for
payment uh I don't know and I also don't
see how it helps you in your current
morass I think it
might help with further implementations
but I don't see how it addresses what
you're describing as a problem and and I
will add to that Madam chair that I hope
somebody's here from the Department so
we can hear from the department at some
point but that's that's my question so I
can tell you that right now so evv is to
be implemented U which is the electronic
visit verification and just so you all
I'm going to give you a 10-second
overview we have a direct support staff
working with an individual let's say
they're working with me they will sign
on to their phone saying they started
services with me today take me wherever
they take me it tracks their geolocation
their start time and their end time and
then enters it into our electronic
systems that's our um HR systems and our
billing systems and then it
automatically builds for us that's
supposed to be implemented November 18th
I think is the day I might be wrong
specifically on the day but mid November
um the the because of everything the
bureau has now pushed that to March now
we're still not getting paid if this
goes into
March you know will it be kicked down
the road again I don't know in the
meantime as well we're starting new rate
work and I sit on the rate work
committee so that's figuring out how
much we're going to pay um for people
like Matt so if I'm like physically
aggressive I might be tier whatever and
the rate goes off to that so we start
that work again tomorrow we picked that
up literally uh tomorrow's Friday right
so we we picked that up tomorrow Friday
at 10: a.m. and so we're not even fixing
or focusing on fixing what's in front of
us right now and we're already starting
to try to make more changes to
everything so how this bill will help is
by forcing some common sense
um I have sent some emails to some
people that have said that you are
further dist stabilizing what currently
exists take a breath let's fix what we
have right now and I think it might take
us 6 months to fix what we have right
now to get our providers set um I mean I
have I can only speak to our
organization I have people coming in my
office sobbing I have people quitting
because they mentally can't take the
stress anymore because families are
calling them now we're losing money hand
over fist paying the families and we're
getting to a point to where we might not
be able to do that now when I I say that
to the bureau I'm sure they'll Infuse us
with cash again
but why do we have to get to that point
and this Common Sense Bill and that's
what it is in my opinion it's it it is
is
fundamentally Common Sense best
practices um to just implement the pilot
program uh it's a great example we
talked about uh rep Nel talked about the
system for billing right so when they
put together New Hampshire easy our
interface looks very different or looked
they're fixing it right now than what
the bureau's interface looked like so if
we need to create a plan to work with
Brian and for some reason there's an
issue with the service
authorization we go down to question 3
six and we say okay it's got to be
checked and changed to whatever it needs
to be changed to they look on their
screen and they're like that's question
three for
us why do they even have a different
interface it doesn't make sense and
these are all things that if we had done
a pilot program and we have done
responsible
implementation we wouldn't have had that
issue and again we have people at the
bureau who are solution-minded that are
helping us work through these issues but
we have a whole Confluence of issues
that are coming forward now with the
rate changes in evv those are the two uh
acts two next acts in this play and if
we don't stop and pause right now I I
mean you have providers that are on
their line of credit and you know every
dollar that they're borrowing to keep
whole and it's affecting massively large
companies they have to pay interest on
that which means that you know when
you're talking about companies that have
2%
margins um you know that might be their
profit for the year which ends up being
like so is a great example we were
talking about canceling our an annual um
Christmas event that we have and I'll
tell you how crazy my event is it cost
us $10,000 a year we have a Santa that
donates their time we have individuals
that drive through what takes the three
of us and five other people a week to
set up with
lights I mean and and we're talking
about cancelling that and people are
calling us I'm saying where is it no I I
get that part it's it's it's the what do
we do about it part that I think we're
trying to get to yeah and if I if I may
Madam chair yes and then I will
stop uh what I'm hearing you say is from
your
perspective um going forward with this
as applied to the other four
aspects of the program recommended by
A&M would be a good thing
is that boiled down to its very essence
what you're telling us yes I it's very
good thank you thank you I appreciate
the interpretation thank you
representative
kofel uh thank you and thank you for
taking my question so would it make
sense at this point to to delay
implementation of the so the the force
the 4 a.m steps because right now we
have a a billing crisis and that's an
acute crisis this and correct me if I'm
wrong but if you run out of money you
can't do at some point you can't deliver
Services right right so does it make
sense I mean potentially legislatively
to just sort of say we've got a a
four-step process but right now we got
to stop the
bleeding and then you know the the
followup to that question would be you
know and if we if we were to do
something like that what would the next
what would you envision as the next step
out of those four steps in the in the
study so thank you very much for your
question so um first off yes we need to
just take a breath and we need to fix
the problems that we have in front of us
deal with the acute nature of of the
issues secondly we need to um work on
some financing that's not direct CMS
dollars so that people don't have to pay
that back immediately by December 31st
um and maybe we can take some State
funds swap that money out and then once
billing is been restored in full have
everyone Implement a repayment plan for
that so that way we can stabilize the
system and we can keep people working
and and all that um so those are the
first two things I would be doing the
the the second aspect of your question
is I I I don't think the order is out of
line I think you know their next steps
into doing rates and doing
evv I it doesn't matter to me I don't I
don't think that matters I think what
matters is just addressing the elephant
in the room right now that seems to be
crushing everyone um and again BDS has
been infusing people with cash as they
need it
but what determines need and how bad is
does it need to get before you get it um
so we had three days left before we had
no more cash to pay bills before we got
an
infusion so is at the level of need and
if that's the case why are we creating
so much stress I mean honest to God if I
had hair I would have lost it all in the
last three months um you know it it's
it's one of those scenarios where like
I've talked to other CEOs they're just
vibrating from stress literally watching
them vibrate from stress so to your your
question it it doesn't matter what order
we go in next they could put evv forward
first or or what not um they've talked
about that they're going to not pursue
the the tier changes which I think is
good because it artificially capitates
people's
needs um and just because the state says
we're not going to pay X Y and Z dollars
doesn't mean that your needs don't far
in way exceed that um I do think that
personally is a bad idea but the rest of
it doesn't
matter representative Merchant
second thank you madam chair this is
again for uh our esteemed colleague
representative
Weber okay
I I hear the concern in the short term
about the issue of funding it's critical
to any organization profit or oper
profit is it possible if BDS is up
against the wall with CMS can someone go
to the fiscal committee and then ask for
the fiscal committee to release funds
that could temporarily back fill BDS in
order for them to meet the target with
CMS at the same time allow for the
agencies to get Ridge loans is that
something we can do through fiscal
committee versus going through
legislative that's question one and the
other one if I understand this correctly
I would say that we're looking at a
five-step process run step one which is
not going well that instead of a pilot
program we build into it a process
through the bill that they have to do a
pilot on each step of the way because
that it's going to take time and
depending upon step two you do a pilot
for step two and see how it works you do
a pilot for step three and see how it
works and a pilot for step four before
you make it broad is that kind of the
concept so it's two things one is R
whatever where can we find the money and
then number two can we possibly think
about this not so much a pilot per se
for everything but a pilot for each
stage yes please the answer to number
one is I have no idea my guess is that
fiscal has a great deal of ability to do
stuff but representative Edwards being
on finance would have a great deal more
information than I would about that
um
yeah but
um I I too was thinking in the same
direction of we have four more steps and
if we are going to do something with the
bill
it would make sense to require a pilot
on each of the four
steps representative Edwards so so just
to speak to the first question about the
authority of the fiscal committee as I
understand the authority of the fiscal
committee we do two things we approve
the acceptance of federal money that's
coming to us and the second thing we do
is we approve requests for
reallocation within the existing budget
to move money from from one part of an
approved budget to another we do not I
think typically have the authority to uh
authorize or approp effectively
appropriate additional money it's we our
Authority stays within the existing
budget that's been approved I believe
okay representative
Merchant re represent Edwards thank you
for that clarification so basically in
my
opinion that money is s sort of fungible
so in other words what the fiscal
committee could do if I understand this
correctly is you could give the
Department of Health Human Services
that's where BDS resides the ability to
move money from one bucket to another
bucket temporarily to get them through
this
process yes I I would just uh reorder
the steps the the uh fiscal request has
to originate with the executive branch
and then it comes to the fiscal
committee as a request and so then we
review and potentially approve the
request but if the department doesn't
ask it we don't make them move
money sorry and clarifying that by it
coming from the executive branch that's
coming from the Department um
specifically the department is a part of
the executive branch yeah
so I N Nathan white is their CFO he he
would have to basically at some point
have his hands on
it thank
you and and then uh represent Mar to
follow up on your your question doing it
step by step makes the most amount of
sense I I think a a pilot project for
each part in implementation would it
slow down the process dramatically I'm
sure it would but at the end of the day
we're talking about people's lifetimes
you know a couple years to get to where
they want to go with this I don't think
is an unreasonable
ask representative nichel thank you for
Madam chairman thanks for taking my
question I'm getting better at doing
this it's been six months um as
representative Edwards said I'm in
private medical practice my world I know
is very different than yours um the
reason why my practice is so successful
is because they don't let me near the
billing um with that said I do see the
financials every month and I do know
that um um
whenever um we change the way we collect
money that there's always a burp and
that our collection rate time changes
and we freak out for a couple months and
then all of the sudden we just get a
huge infusion of cash um when we catch
up is there any possibility that that's
going to happen here yeah that's that's
exactly what we're being told is going
to happen but the problem is as we get
through one problem we get to the next
and as we get to the next problem we get
to the next so this was all supposed to
be resolved OLED by mid July and then it
was supposed to be resolved by mid
August and then by mid September and now
we're in mid October and now we're being
told it'll resolve by December 31st when
we had our meeting this week we were
being told that we need to give a
repayment plan something uh to BDS and
my response was pay us in full and I
will pay you in full I will cut a check
the same day we get our money and if
that works for you that works for me but
we're not going to agreee to anything um
you know and and in the form that they
submitted to all of us one of the things
that really irked me was it saids that
once you agree to this repayment plan
that they were trying to get everyone to
do you can't contest it you can't
augment it you have to accept it and you
wave all your rights to be able to do
that to me it's just we're worrying
about CMS and I have to I've worked with
CMS in other parts of the country
if we're this concerned with CMS there
is a reason why and I would highly
recommend delving into why we're this
concerned with C we're not listening
that something needs to happen and now
they no longer are willing to give us
what we need any which way that needs to
probably be addressed there needs to be
someone looking at that specifically
because I've never had an experience
with CMS where they've been anything
other than helpful and um I mean there's
always been issues like Florida I was in
Florida when Florida actually went
through a similar transition as New
Hampshire we had a couple months where
there was no payment but Florida turned
around and said hey this is what the
issue is it's a software issue if you
need money come to us but they fixed
that issue within a month and a
half so we're just so far beyond that
point at this point uh and again you
have great people at BDS working these
issues daily but if we had had a pilot
program we wouldn't have this issue can
I one yes one more um so several times
you said we need to take a deep stop
take a deep breath who actually stops
and takes a deep breath is that us or is
that who that that's BDS that's DHHS and
we have no control over that uh it's I
think legislatively with this with this
uh piece of legislation you would
because you'd be commanding them to not
move any not move forward without doing
a pilot program
and I just with everything going on and
you have to understand that people at
BDS are just as stressed as we are
because they're trying to fix this whole
monster of a mess and yet now either
someone's directing them to or they're
taking upon themselves to start
implementing the next steps when we have
this Quagmire of an issue that's
dragging everyone down representative
Merchant thank you madam chair but that
is my concern right now even though we
may talk about doing each phase as a
pilot there's nothing at this point in
time because in order for this to become
effective it won't happen until next
summer so is the department on a
timeline to implement all five stages
before next summer because if it is this
becomes
relevant I don't know if they're on a
timeline the things that were of concern
that there was a CMS timeline for were
the things that needed to be implemented
on July 1st of this year and that was
the direct Bill and conflict free case
management so those two things were
implemented on July 1st so that's the
First Act of this play that we're in the
middle of um the rate changes are not
required by CMS I know that so there's
no reason that that can't be stopped and
halted evv is a um a system requirement
from CMS the uh electronic visit
verification um but I don't understand
why we can't ask for a way favor on that
um because that is not a a item that's
been out there for a decade plus like
the other
one thank you I think we've had a lot of
good information here um I think that we
need to figure out from the Department
um what insight there is and speaking to
people around the country it seems that
other states have been able to um have a
firmer relationship with CMS and I think
our role as legislators in requiring
them to take process yes they can take a
considered process but if the
legislature requires it it gives them a
little bit more backing as they're
working with CMS so I want to thank you
gentlemen for being here and offering
this Insight um and I was wondering if
you um if you would like to speak for
the
Department yes I I should have issued an
Ethics disclosure at the beginning of
and I just say it now yes you may okay
so everything I've said today is in my
role as State Rep I also happen to sit
on the board of one sky I was not
speaking on behalf of one sky at any
point I was speaking on behalf of what I
think is taking place
systemwide and I happen to have
knowledge of one sky to which I'm
extrapolating the impact across the
entire system so okay um so in case
anyone's worried that I was testifying
as a one sky board member I was
representing my my role in the legisl
okay thank you representative Edwards
since you weren't at the microphone in
case there is anybody listening
representative Edwards was speaking in
his role as a legislator not as board or
anything else even though he's a board
member of One sky thank
you good afternoon Madam chair U members
of the committee my name is Melissa nth
I am the attorney and legislative
liaison for the Bureau of Developmental
Services uh and so I think you know a
lot of some of the things that um Mr
cord was speaking about he was giving
some kudos to the department um and so I
think that's very much appreciated and
the department does recognize as he
indicated that there were some you know
some problems with billing and really
has taken some concerted efforts to work
with individual ageny is to make sure
that these things are getting sorted out
going forward um and so what I'm what
I'm told is that there there are staff
at the bureau that are working directly
with uh on Sky to try to help and deal
with any issues there were um as this
was rolling out there were issues on the
department side there were issues on the
area agency side um and I think we're
trying to work the department is trying
to work to make sure it's clarified its
own issues and working with the region
to help assist with any issues they may
still have um I'm told that some of
these issues are um happen to be
specific to this one Area Agency uh not
that not to say that the that that's a
good or bad thing but just to say there
are specific and so the department is
vested in working with them through
whatever issues those might be to ensure
these things are going to happen going
forward um as far as the the rest of the
system is concerned with the direct
billing as of got to get my notes here
I'm
sorry as of the end of September 88% of
the providers that had active service
authorizations with the Department have
build on those authorizations um so
that's encouraging to see that any
issues that were there are you know it's
not to say they they're perfect but
they're being worked on in the fact that
88% of providers that had these service
authorizations have built on those um
only about 3 months into this system I
think is really encouraging um so with
that I'd be happy to take if there are
any specific questions I will do my best
to answer them and maybe that I don't
have that information today we may need
to take that back but I'll do my best um
thank you um before I recognize
representative Weber I had one question
from your statement you said that 80 88%
of providers with authorizations have
built how many are waiting on
authorizations that I don't know I would
have to ask I'm sorry I don't have that
information today thank you
representative
Weber so I'm just trying to get at the
end end
question um if we were to
pass
a what is the Department's position on
the passage of
um basic what is basically this bill
only applied to the four remaining
stages of the
implementation so the department doesn't
feel that there needs to be uh that
these need to be stopped and there
although there are kind of four I would
call them elements that are going to be
implemented rather than stages because a
lot of things are happen happening
simultaneously um so the Department's
plan to give you an overview for the
rest of this year um is to continue to
work specifically with with all
stakeholders but most importantly with
individuals and families um
before you know learning all the
information they can despite and this
has been going on this is not new um
there have been
354 stakeholder meetings um since the
fall of 2021 and when I say stakeholders
that's a variety that includes the area
agencies families providers um everyone
across the system so that those efforts
are going to continue and one of the the
next steps is to make some changes to
the waiver services and the department
is continuing to before going forward
with that is making every effort to
ensure they've heard from families to
make sure that before these things roll
out and service Services get change that
they are being included um you you heard
a lot of reference to rates um the
department is engaged with uh another
consultant Myers and stoer uh who is
working on the rate development and so
that is uh continuing to go forward as
well with getting there's been a lot of
work that's gone into that um and I know
you had asked about some some deadlines
again I would have to get specifics I'm
not I don't have that information with
me today but um I don't know where the
department is at in so far as its
contracts with with these various
contractors and what the um metrics are
for completion in those that those may
have some timelines although I don't
know that specifically um so that may be
while it's not a CMS deadline um that
may be something that the department is
considering when it is doing this
work representative
merch it's encouraging thank you for the
question also thank you for the chair
it's encouraging to hear the 88%
number I would be interested though to
understand if understand the agency
there 10 in the state of New Hampshire
and therefore is that 80% apply to every
single one collectively or can we get a
breakdown by agency building is one
thing receiving cash is another thing so
just because they built it doesn't mean
that we actually paid it so I'm looking
for okay what's the payment against that
88% if we get 10% payment against the 80
88% build that's not going to help them
in a cash flow
point I can I can look into that I don't
think I have the information on that I'm
looking to see if that was anything that
was provided to me
um if I may sure I think it's a critical
point because just because something was
built to the
system is
encouraging however the real issue I
think right now is the cash flow what's
coming back from the State against those
invoices that were build because that's
where the I think a lot of the pressure
is coming from is they're not getting
the cash from the state to pay their
bills I don't know the specific
percentage of that um but there were
there is an electronic billing system
and I there were some difficulties with
that and so the department as a way to
help actually did some manual billing
and invoicing um and so at this point
and again this was through the end of
September and I don't know the total
amount that was buil so I know it
doesn't get specifically to your
question but to give you an idea of the
amount of money that's been paid out um
the electronic system processed $43
million
and manually $44 million were processed
so 87 million did go out in payments but
again I don't know specifically how much
was built so I would have to look into
that um thank you and before uh I would
really appreciate getting the
information on the number that are still
waiting for prior authorizations the
number of providers who are billing the
num the impact on the area agencies um
and their ability to operate and
continue to provide their vital service
and also seeing where the manual billing
versus the electronic billing is because
um the fact that 3 months in over half
of it is being done through manual
billing thank you for getting people
paid but that that's not showing that
the electronic system is yet as robust
as it needs to be I my understanding is
there's a plan at that deoy here we go
with another consultant that the
department is working with um is
planning to have that fixed I think I
was told by next Friday um and I don't
know if that fixes everything if that
fixes part of it but I know it is in the
in the works who really there's a big
effort to get that all fixed but I can
get more specifics for you thank you yes
the more specifics the better and um
with my experience in the business world
the more more Consultants you have
operating the more potential for chaos
um especially when you're taking on
multiple
projects
um
see um I I think that we absolutely need
to have more information on this and it
determine how big of a problem this is
because it sounds like the department
seeing the successes that have happened
which is good and I'm glad that there
are those successes but I want to make
sure that the actual experience on the
ground on these providers is also
showing success before you move into
more steps and uh more of these
important and challenging changes to the
system um just representative
Weber I agree I agree and and so it
seems clear to me that we're going to
need at least one more meeting yes um
and time is short and I am missing
representative McMahon's voice saying
while we're still young uh but I'm
wondering how to proceed could you
remind me because there have been so
many different subcommittees is this one
that was noticed in the calendar or is
this one that was given this was noticed
in the calendar we have one other
outstanding subcommittee on the two-
tiered waiver system that's largely made
up of the same members so if we meet at
the same time same day for though that
and this that would help make us uh be a
little bit more efficient on our timing
um so I just I just feel that this is a
big enough issue that calendar notice is
a really makes me feel a lot better
about what we're doing and I'm going to
retract a lot of what I said earlier
because I thought that there was a
restriction in the bill that I can't
find so it's not there um but I I I do
think we need to have at least one
more um meeting where we have a
considerable amount more information and
um you know I think I think we need to
hear from the people who are doing the
implementing
because if we don't hear from them that
this
is you know I I'm far from convinced
that a solution is happening and
um so I think it would be very helpful
to hear from the people who are doing
the implementing
about specifically the effects of
requiring specifically that each each uh
of the other four elements have a pilot
program and I see no reason why the
pilot programs could not perhaps
proceed I I wouldn't go as far as saying
you can't start on the next one before
you finish the last one but because I
don't have enough knowledge of the
process but I'd really like some
feedback by the people who will have to
do the implement
about what the effect of doing that
would have on their operations
directly I think that would be very
helpful I I know I personally um I had
reached out to associate commissioner
santanello to see if she was able to
make this meeting and it didn't fit her
calendar um I definitely would want to
schedule it when she can come here as
well because I think this is a lot of
coordination um and we want to make sure
that since she is coordinating for the
Bureau of Department of Developmental
services that we make sure sure that we
understand what she's seeing as well so
that we can make sure that we're all
moving forward in the in the most
productive way in order to get these
Services when next uh we will need to
schedule that so we will query out to
ourselves we will query out to her as
well um so that we can get something
noticed um we'll have to notice it by
next Wednesday so that we can get into
that following
calendar so we're looking at Halloween a
week folks most
likely hopefully it won't be as scary as
all of the tricks
so you don't want to pull the committee
now on their availability um we could do
that um I was the other bill that talk
about were meeting uh we haven't
scheduled the other Bill 317 yet um it's
largely the same same members the one
who's not on this committee is already
here today with US Representative n upam
so we uh we could pull on the
availability for that week I think that
might help and then if we could give the
assistant commissioner our our
availabilities maybe can
work well and and as soon as you know
let let's pull our calendars I'm going
to have to pull mine because um just I'm
moving pieces with all my different
people and what they're trying to deal
with at home so we'll do that we'll get
this noticed as soon as we can we'll
reach out to the associate you're going
to do that via email I think we should
do that via email all right yes no
problem fantastic this has been um
incredibly helpful um I really
appreciate understanding just the depth
of these challenges because we're not
always we don't always always have
visibility into the consequences of our
actions and the department action so
thank you very much and I really look
forward to finding a good solution uh M
Madam chair yes if I could from the
Department do you have a list of the
agencies and how I could possibly reach
out to them we've heard from one sky
which is tremendous thank you both for
being here three of you but I'd like to
listen to the other agencies as well if
I had to make a personal phone call to
them to understand what issues they're
having as
well um I might suggest that we divide
that list up I mean I think some of us
like I already know some of the folks at
gateways I could reach out to them but
that would make for a division of labor
and I think we could each come back to
the next uh to the next meeting with
some some input um and when I said there
are 10 area agencies but because of the
requirements of CMS that provid as a
service have opportunity to directly
bill for services themselves there are
now many more agencies that are billing
than just those 10 area agencies um so I
I can easily get a list of the area
agencies and I believe on the
Department's website there is a list of
all the providers enrolled to provide
each type of service um it's a very
lengthy list I and so I can we can get
that link um if it's helpful I can get
that directly to the the chair um get
that information to her and you can go
from there if that's helpful yeah if we
could get the link I think that would be
very helpful the link would be wonderful
sometimes the website's a little harder
to access when you AR design involved in
designing it yes you refer to the the
providers I me understand something to
help me anyways one is you have the
agency is the way it was before the
agency did the building on behalf of the
providers now the providers can build
directly to Medicaid that's correct yes
that's part of the corrective action
plan that the was under was that because
we did not previously allow that so is
the goal here ultimately is for the
providers to build directly to Medicaid
yes and that's a CMS
Rule and reason I'm shaking my head is I
have
a a daughter who is a physical therapist
and she cringes at the idea of doing
billing herself and it's the requirement
is that we have the state has to provide
that opport Unity if an agency does not
want to bill for itself it can engage
with a trading partner it has that
opportunity but the where the state had
to come into the corrective action plan
is we did not previously allow them the
opportunity if they wanted
to um and then as far as information um
we also have um some of those questions
about whether some funds could be
requested to be reallocated in order to
cover this as a longer term Bridge until
the system is fully functioning so we
would like to have information on that I
know that that would need to go to
fiscal but I think that would go a long
way for us to feel better about what the
process is so we can stay involved and
then it sounded like there was also an
issue around the room and board billing
that I guess had been previously wrapped
I I assume it had been previously
wrapped up into other issues but I want
to make sure that right now all of our
constituents are having trouble paying
their bills we have an obligation to pay
for that room in board for the people
who are served by BDS um how can we make
sure that that line item has what's
necessary so that they can afford to so
that the people providing Services can
keep a roof over their head and food on
their plate so have that information as
well would be very helpful okay okay
thank you are there any further requests
that's so complex we may end up
following up with a couple emails as
well sorry thank you and
actually and for D thank you so much for
being here yes and then with one other
comment or
request I would highly recommend that
you folks take the opportunity to reach
out to the private provider Network and
speak to their director they represent
um the vast majority of the um the
vendor agencies in our state and I think
they would be much more comfortable
having a private conversation than one
that is going to be publicly broadcasted
based upon the conversations I've had
with uh many of those members um there's
a a very palpable concern of sharing
information will lead to not receiving
funds with that being said I haven't
seen anything that would substantiate
that but let alone I it's a concern that
is very widely
shared thank you if you could provide
that information to me I can send that
out in a collective email once I get all
of these different contact points and
that concern is one we deal with on
other bills we have plenty of people who
will speak to us but the last thing they
want to do is face potential
retribution
I unless anybody else has uh any
anything else to say I believe that uh
we will pull the members for our
availability speak with the associate
commissioner and then see when we'll be
meeting again so thank you very much
this is
adored